l a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a nessuno
video sono ma vivi che mi sono fatto
malissimo sono fa vj oggi siamo su multi
tasker condividete ragazzo tuttofare
questo questo gioco qui è uno dei giochi
che nella mia vita odiato di più perché
già lo conoscete o perché se non parte e
difficile spiegare ma le ragazze parte
ste cagate allora è un cieco che ti
carica abbastanza bisogna fare
praticamente bisogna resistere a dei
mini mini giochi tra virgolette mentre
faccio stacca greco prefetto mentre
faccio st cagata praticamente devo farne
un'altra insieme adesso devo tenere devo
muovere sto così non blu per evitare nei
triangoli un macello
ovviamente devo tenere sulla pallina
muovere questo è pensate sia finita qui
ovviamente no perché container squares
before devo fare in 26 cosi ragazzi io
non sono mai riuscito nella mia vita a
fare un punteggio che c'entra questa
cosa ve lo dico che è botta di culo
incredibile la palla era perso perso
person una merda un che spero che
abbiate capito di che cosa si tratta e
un macello e anche bello pesante ho
tentato di evitare questo momento da
sempre perché sapevo che prima o poi
sarei finito a fare sta roba sono era
ero convinto proprio fino a 2 il bello
che si chiama multitasche sto gioco
perché proprio c'è nel senso più per
fare più operazioni insieme levi
controllati con un casino lo conoscevo
ma non lo so non sono mai riuscito a
fare una partita decente store cioè ok
ok madonna che fenomeni caricato la
parola trova roba
tenete presente che tipo questo e molti
task 1 perché hanno fatto anche il 2
ovviamente visto schifo
lo sapete che non ce la farò mai nella
vita finisco gioco e no è solo per per
dirmelo perché è impossibile ci giocavo
ragazzi quando ero un po più piccolo non
mi ricordo per quali problemi mentali
però ci giocavo e mi ricordo che non ho
mai fatto una partita decente sono
sempre morte macello una volta batterà
il record mondiale che a me lo sento mai
carico frega un cazzo si madonna tanta
tanta roba ragazzo e stavolta ce la
faccio devo battere 57 che record norma
fatte in vetta io le voglio capire chi
dio santissima che qualcuno che se n'è
uscito dicendo ma che bello facciamo
questa roba fantastica i rivolta come un
calzino amico migliore su facebook the
vabbè qualcos'altro non lo sapevo non ce
la farò mai a vincere starò male che
impossibile dovete premere la barra
spaziatrice un macello
[Musica]
dio mio cosa ho fatto
ragazzi non c'è al sono arrivato al 100
è un miracolo divino
ecco adesso adesso è arrivata non volevo
parlarne prima che magari non ci
arrivavo più perfetto
la parola pare gas capisco più un cazzo
eh già io capisco poco di mio perché
sono stupido inizio si vabè raga ma non
è possibile
io non so con che criterio abbiano fatto
un gioco del jazz è assurdo la
difficoltà di somme è aumentata mi
prendete per il culo al cuore è va beh
certo sì ma gesù cristo no vabbè ragazzi
io 120 credo che non farò mai più di
questo punteggio nella mia vita
bellei sia musica ragazzi che ti gasa di
brutto però non riesci mai a fare un
cazzo uguale quindi sembrava persa per
il culo praticamente sto gioco è
fantastico fantastico una sega ci deve
essere qualcuno talmente malato da
inventarsi cose credo
ok ok mio dio sono arrivato di malta al
punto di prima non so neanche come non
me lo chiedete devo devo battere 122 ma
la vedo durissima perché mentre stavo
dicendo san fratello rischiato di morire
26 volte io non solo anche come ho fatto
arrivare a 122 è impossibile ma è così
madonna la propaggine la pagine capitana
porca non farò mai più un
gioco come questo simile perché
è una merda vi indecente affanculo
bene a tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
video sono fa vj e oggi siamo su multi
task 2 carino dove bisogna comandare
tanti mini giochi diversi ma
hanno fatto veramente anche il 2 di
stack agata che vi devo dire una colpa i
ragazzi voluto fare anche il 2 perché
sono un deficiente no perché ha sì anche
per quella era la casa che c'è diversa
dalle due l'uno e che evel due ragazzi
ovviamente si muove dieci volte più
veloce un macello
le quattro cagate solite che avete già
visto prima ce ne sono altre due
genitori a ce ne sono sei in total
macello voglio vedere se riesco ad
arrivarci prima di tutto a 6 per
impossibile io secondo me non ci
arriverò mai neanche prima della fine
dell'episodio ad arrivare a 6 e assurdo
sono anche un rincoglionito perché me le
dirà l'obiettivo ragazzi a 100 se arriva
a 100 mi vide nudo in pubblico ma non lo
stava a fare il primo dovrà rompere il
cazzo però anche con questo cioè senza
arrivare al sesto livello cioè già
questi di loro sono già fin casi nati di
prima cioè io gli ho una teoria ragazzi
o ai quattro braccia o gioco non lo puoi
fare ciò è assurdo gli mortacci chi deve
morire la famiglia io nella vita
reale non riesco ad ascoltare e fare
un'altra cosa contemporaneamente quindi
figuriamoci tenere quattro mini giochi
di merda impossibilitato se se ci arrivò
a farlo vede mi chiamo madonna cosa ho
fatto
non avete mi sono ucciso per fast a
parte quello di correre ok ok ragazzi
non sto guardando mita dell'ecri
christian non si può fare sto schifo non
posso più vedere cioè io non dormo da da
da quando ho aperto il canale perché
sapevo di doverlo fare sappiate quando
aperto fa vigenti ma ho detto oh cazzo
prima o poi dovrò fare multi tasker
maledetta la vita quanta merda e vabbè
vuoi aggiungere qualcosa è partita
meglio del solito anche se di solito
faccio pagare pre partita meglio se ce
la posso fare credo non me la tiro
se faccio le corone un'altra volta mi
ammazzo già un po verdi jersey ed è
ovvio è una roba ci manca solo che devo
cucinare anche fatemelo sapere che 60
ragazzi 60 mio dio
se salta non ci posso credere più alto
del mio voto
d'esame la posso fare stavo casse non se
non compariva l'altro morivo sì mi sono
salvato lusso come non mi chiedete sono
morte 84 cervelli oro ci rinuncio
comunque ragazzi a chopin il papa che ce
n'era ancora uno ancora un c'è fotte
sega si no madonna ok perfetto perché ci
siamo sono carichi sono abbiamo perso
qualcuno ragazzi siamo ci siamo ci
abbiate abbiamo provato in due parole ma
era toro far vivere solo questo pezzo
per arrivare a questo a questo punto qui
io e mio padre ci abbiamo messo delle
ore letteralmente quindi mi sembra
divertente anche farvi vedere che cosa è
successo nel mentre l'epicità bravo è
però li mette tutti insieme cioè nel
senso poi adesso ne mette un altro beta
ecco che più di faccia questo che questo
no
ecco siccome io lo sto facendo da 45
minuti da solo mi servirebbe che tu mi
non mi sta testando il cavo tutti ultimi
20 anni in bilico la pallina si aspetta
no non apparivano da solo non ce la
faccio più vuole fece la famiglia in una
casa ce ne sono 6 da fare uno vorrebbe
farne 6 se ci riesci cioè che noi
storicamente mi sono distratto i secondi
non andava sul cabotaggio
la minchia e quindi ragazzi che disastro
che possono veramente avevo il terrore
di fare questa cosa quindi ragazzi se il
video è piaciuto non mi resta che dirvi
lasciato momento mi piace per ogni mi
piace mio padre riceverà un cappello in
più in testa e io uno in meno forse lo
restituì sfilatini civ il diavolo
prossimo vito vedo ragazzi